all right
there we go we go like we're live
uh for the first a session and that is
ask me anything of 2020
and i've already got a lot of questions
that's why i'm starting starting a
little bit
uh early just uh it's 11 58 here and i
was supposed to start
at noon but i see all questions so i
thought i would i would jump
into them right away um so bob head it
asks what is the line between justice
and forgiveness
um there isn't a line between just
justice forgiveness this is one of those
sort of questions where you're asking
a overly broad big picture
thing unless you're indexing it to
somebody's ideas or
sort of conceptions coming from
somewhere where it's not answerable
because there isn't justice in the
abstract
as we can say very much about there's
there's justice as understood through
particular
theories some of them are better
perspectives than others and like
likewise
forgiveness there's one history of
literature about that this going all the
way back back
prior to um you know christian up
inappropriation
of greek philadelphia and well into to
aristotle for ferdil his discussions
of freakness so you know if in order to
answer a question like that i think you
probably want to like
read around in the literature and a
quick google search we'll find and do
all sorts of stuff about
forgiveness that might be quite
interesting another similar question to
sean
hamelin one ways if any of the reading
of the old testament not superior to an
average
christian christian one in ways is the
average christian read superior
if any no such thing as the jewish
reading
or an average christian reading that's
sort of nonsense sensical
non-starters you can talk about about a
wide range of
readings within what we we now recognize
is atheism whether we're talking about
you know
the wrinkle movement the deeds you know
through the pharisees into present-day
judaism or whether we wanted to bring in
his sick
reading that's a reaction against um
some of the
overly rabbinical stuff whether we want
about reform and re-corruptionist
readings there is no jewish reading and
the more that we
read around where we we discover that
uh just thinking earlier today too about
you know the
the yeah well it was earlier today
earlier yesterday
about how people talk about the bible
as a book and you know
what a mistake that is because it's it's
the books
and when you're you know i was talking
with a friend of mine about about
biblical literature the other day today
and we're attacking attack the wisdom
literature with which both have an intro
interest in and i'm different than
that's from say the general idol uh
you know book book of joshua you know um
thing things you know you know along
along these lines
it's not there's just one one single
text that you read
it's all these texts that brought
together there i i won't even know what
the average christian reading is
what christian would you be referring to
like an american
uh evangelical who has a bible app and
then like reads pages each day
and maybe goes to the bible study are
you talking about you know
um a catholic are you talking about an
eastern orthodox person
you know this isn't an answerable
question here's one that is answerable
zach how are you are you doing today
doctor said
i'm doing okay okay um i have been
taking it relatively easy over the last
few day days um i did a lot
more um
hanging out you know my my and i have
been doing things
like you know playing chess ass and
players and she's been doing
really great cooking over over the last
days i'm about to
uh do some some other other stuff fairly
easily so
i see somebody complaining champions in
stack it was awful
you know on his ugg uh man
chad is really really complete a lot uh
i want to tell you about about the prop
the audio you know it's
right i've got the tech that i have
um the internet isn't working great the
internet that isn't working
i live in an apartment we have one big
internet feed i don't control all of
these sorts of things i can check the
audio the audio is fine on my end
you know get my bike here and
i've got you know i've already tapped
hands like the the
here the problem with the inner internet
you know uh the things that people worry
about about
i have control over these things all
right back to back to stuff
so useless project said in your last q a
albert camus
with some great ideas but you just
disagree with them could you go into
some details
i would disagree with him on his
velocity of the absurd yeah i mean i
think he
closed off transcendence in ways similar
to nietzsche
that i just think you know it's it's a
choice on his part
it doesn't have to be so um
i had some of his reading of people he's
he's a pretty
good reader other philosophers but you
know he's
he's going to get things all off i don't
think he takes
uh kierkegaard and chest off as
seriously
as he does as he could
um i think think that it comes to
kafka it's a mistake to say to say the
[ __ ] is sort of like
the culmination of of kafka's work work
but you know
he's got interesting reading readings
and reasons for why he's
putting fourth position since that he is
right right
um matthew hopkins and says happy new
year
i've been working working through a card
a lot recently i was hoping you could
say a few
few words wax edm image irritation too
too is he making
a case for the amazing capacity of the
face with
raw substance material information
coming from the inside world
or more to it oh there's there's there's
a couple things going on there
he's he's like thinking about the nature
of physical
substance and that some of the
properties of it
are what lock is going to later on call
secondary properties things that
are essentially in our minds the way we
interpret the thing
right rather than the thing is in itself
you know at bottom atom what extended
substance
is extension and it's it's
mathematizable
and it can be understood in a variety of
right ways descartes thinks modern
science can get out so that's
that's one thing on there the other
thing that's that's important in it that
is saying listen listen it ein has
different activities i mean if you look
at the kojito
that's talked about before that um
and he says he says well what is a
thanks and he enumerates all these
different modes of thinking that's a
really important spot
in in meditation so that a lot of people
passed and they're like yeah of course
you know the thing that doubts and that
blah blah blah right right now each one
of those
is a mode of thinking
birthday card part really quite
important
and um what is it that that that
grasps the what's going on there with
the
the um sub-substance of the
wax well that's not not fences
themselves right or the imagination
it's it's wrapped around the intellect
but what grasps all these other
properties the senses so
it's showing us that our mind skins can
be played
at the same time in a variety of
different different ways through the
same same
object i'll also i'll tell you another
thing about cart
so so emotions are mode modes of thought
cart right cause
else could they be and and so
um what feel to towards something like
let's say we have an aesthetic response
since
through the pieces of wet like it could
be like
nostalgia about the time they melted
waxed whether with our
our beloved family making souls for
christmas or something like that
that would be yet in another mode of
apprehending the object
um the emotions that are that are
involved in their passions for
for dick so there's a lot of this thing
you can read
into it the more that you read across
the art more you're going to discover
um how much other stuff
is is going on right so
all right i see some people still
complaining about audio
nothing to do about it you know if it's
if it's really bothering you
jump off right
i control it so i've done everything i
i do i end um
all right uh let's see here dylan says
what thoughts on
buddhism how compatible is it with other
philosophy
stoicism what buddhism
is is there a buddhism because if you
read text textbooks if you actually like
go around and spend time with people who
are buddhists you're gonna find a very
significant variance between
say theravada monks in in sri lanka
and uh pure land buddhist
practicing in japan or like my family
does in chicago
or uh zebudus or you know
sort of people doing amount of mountains
things in the presence like
the all the other new types buddhism
that emerged in the 20th century
um so
what do i think i think of that buddhism
is is quite interesting i think it's a
vast
philosophical and real religious
tradition that goes back
uh millennia that we should be very very
cool about generalizing too much about
bosom as such and we have to be very you
know
with the think of what buddhism are we
are we talking about i mean
pure land buddhism is one of the
most widespread versions but i don't see
a lot of people who talk about buddha
buddhism
actually about purely land buddhism
and the whole idea of you know the pure
land and what it means
but who take buddhism seriously know all
about a thing
is it compatible with other philosophies
it depends on what you what you mean by
compatible
um any anything is compatible with
anything else
if you want to fudge fudge nurse you
kind of smoosh them together
but um you know there are places where
it's where you just have to
uh pick a news right right or you're
gonna have to
say i like this but i like that and so
you know you know stoicism says that
there is an actual self cell buddhism
says there
isn't they're they're not totally
incompatible
uh uh because the the self self of
stylism is
not just this room part thing whatever
that
happens to be epic just act as it's a
system of
of uh nominee
um uh appearances uh
impressions so um
yeah um
i i think you know you can ask about
what it's what it's connected to
in in other ways but so we'll move on to
the next next one
actually i just just got a text um
all right so
andrew says people who haven't developed
it emotionally and wisely wisely as
grump
and and experiences do you have on us do
you do you think there's a danger of
following certain philosophies people
people who haven't did emotionally um
i imagine that has to do
with like
so people who are young people who
haven't people have
experienced trauma and are trying to try
to make sense of things
is there a danger of following in
philosophy yeah and
following they would be like
unaccordingly
jumping off embracing it the way that
that people
take on self-help programs or diets or
other things like like that
and that would be yeah kind of uh
kind of foolish um there's
there's no philosophy that you can't
misunderstand
and and use so
are there are there some that you should
avoid i guess you should say say
it's not so much too much that you avoid
philosophy so fees
it's that should avoid taking
on uh ways of
of uh making sense of
of them um
you have to approach touch them in light
right
and so actually it may be useful to
embrace
what we call the typical
um you know insight which is
goes all the way back to plato's academy
when it took a skeptical turn
and it's been talked about recently by
philosophers like otto
mccarthy um german german foster in the
20th century
you the way to address a philosophy
that's totalizing
is you could say taking up too much of
your your life space is bring in another
philosophy
and and have sort of balance each other
out
william williams you know talked about
that as a kind of plural pluralism so i
think that that would
that would be a way to do it do it um
[Music]
all right well people keep keep talking
about the audio-ish issue
uh there's not really anything i can do
about that
i mean we mean we can we can this
and you know uh there's there's no uh uh
there's no no repeat because i'd have to
set up an entirely new new
thing for it right um but i
don't know i don't know what to tell you
you know
microphone i see working so
all right let's take the next one um
here here we go jeff f says
uh how much time do you think
non-specialists should spend philosophy
if if unskills and obligations other
fields and deep study of philosophy to
take time those
was what to do well you devote the time
time that you've got
you know um you can it is about how you
devote your time that you have you have
you can
use uh avail moments my wife and i were
just talking about this today hey
you know in the downtime that you have
five minutes
here 20 minutes there you could watch tv
or watch a video or
get involved in twitter dispute or you
could read full philosophy
um there's there's only so many hours
hours in the day
i guess any consolation and those us who
who do follow more or less
full time we don't have enough time to
do everything that we want to do
um i don't know any of my my peers
who actually have enough to themselves
so yeah uh
i don't know what to say about about
about that um
let's see what else
do we have we have a lot of quests here
uh
mason yes what are some some key things
to keep in mind when anyone approaching
work and thought of out of higgle
you're gonna have to read and read
there is no uh mask hegel
there is no um shortcut to
studying eagle um you know
this this is all sort of negative stuff
right right i'm saying but i think it
could
be useful because i love people
as if hegel is something that you just
um take on um
and and you know master you can't even
that i answered a quora question a while
back somebody asked asked how do you
mash stoicism in those lives like
you don't that's that's not the right
way about it
you acknowledge that you are now now
study
something that that covers a lot of
uh things and you have to do a lot of
work to
to you know understand and you know each
each time that you put it in it's in
it's kind of an if process you get to a
certain plateau
toe and now you see a bit further that's
that's
even more more so with hey i would say
and this is a bit of advice
that i often give try to start out with
a phenomenology i know a lot of
people love to to talk about the
phenomenology
but it's sort of sort of like mark is
capital you know people people brag
having read it and made sense of it it's
a very very difficult work
and you're better off starting something
a little bit easier to
make sense of like you know
i always recommend hegel's lectures in
the philosophy of history
his lectures on the history of
philosophy as good
starting places oh that actually answers
isaac zurich
his question about prerequisites before
trying to read hay i don't think you
have to have prerequisites before
they're trying to read hale
uh but you don't want to start out
rereading the phenomenology but a lot of
science levels of logic right
um i mean you could actually want to
have a
b book that's one of one of the not let
lectures like publish bush boston out
with
philosophy of right wouldn't be bad um
it still is is a tough book but
it could could be better
all right uh lokash says what's your
take on charles sanders
purse's pragmatism and purse is very
interesting author
he is uh one of the first people to
start
writing and identifying pragmatism as
such and then william james
as many of you know jump in and takes
over the word and then burst change
changes
his word his term to pragma pregnant
pragmatism and says
i'm making words so ugly so nobody like
james will come along
and and take over from me
um so yeah
um purse is a really really important
figure
and i i think that all worth studying
doesn't get studied an
awful lot and and if you're interested
in american pragmatism
you know the key figures ears are purse
james
and then usually they talk about about
do you should probably talk about
royce tastes a long way and it would
hurt to study uh
george santayana as well
all right mark says are there any any
questions surprised if you've never been
asked in an ama
um i think i get a lot more
questions about philosophy
and and i mean in a very broad sense you
know where it where it bleeds over into
religion
and and also some like we can call pop
psychology stuff i get asked a lot more
about that
than i do things having to do to do with
like matters that i've discussed in my
adler's stories videos or my personal
videos
and i and i say i'm kind of surprised
because people don't care more about
those those sorts of things i mean i
mean i see any people asking
about religion and and all of that
that's gonna be the the main thing
people are
interested um so yeah i guess that that
would be my and my answer
there uh
columns yes have i ever heard of the
kyoto school of philosophy
if so do you have any thoughts on the
subject yeah i've heard of the kyoto
school i learned about them back in grad
school i haven't read any of them so
i don't have any thoughts on um subject
um stephen hi dr sandler is or is a
christian i think do you ever struggle
well with your faith if so how do you
approach
struggle i think this struggle is
necessary for cultivating faith itself i
think
um you've got to be very careful just
like
when i was talking about like you know
the generic christian or
jewish reading on scripture uh not to
try to take
what person and experiences or or
finds word for them and extrapolate it
out everybody
um yeah of course you know you know i
think anybody
thinker and who is religious in any
sense and starting to struggle with
their religious and don't that's
probably because they they
haven't very much um it necessary i mean
i've known real people who seem to have
a perfectly good faith life
without having to go through being about
philosophical issues
um christine actually talked that you
know old women
who have never read um anything because
they're illiterate and they understand
faith hope and charity better than
theologians do because they practice it
so
is it is it necessary to have that i
don't think so
um how do you approach struggles it
depends on the
struggle there's not like there's a
recipe
i mean i think the more that you you
lead and arm yourself with with things
that you can
mull over and connect off with other
people who
have run into similar issues or maybe
haven't maybe maybe maybe you asked them
and they have that that's probably
helpful right
so all right uh
jdd what bands are albums immediately to
come to mind
you would consider existential been
listening to everywhere end of time and
it's a tough listen like if neil suren
hadn't had a soundtrack
totally depends on what kind of
existentialists were thinking about
um you know uh
existentium is not just the frenchies
and
with you know nietzsche uh um
kierkegaard and heidegger yeah there's a
whole bunch of bags of stencil
thinkers and and i i mean i don't think
i don't know that there's any particular
bands or albums that i say are are
particularly
existential except in that they talk
about
like fish you know think about for
example
which einder gen general and their song
love on smack
right uh which is essentially about
falling in love in love with a pratuit
in in the early 80s or maybe
70s knees and and trying to forge virgil
life
and um hurting on him
existential i guess it is
what are you going to uh
you know what do you call existential i
mean
there's there's that rush song right
free will
uh which is definitely you know saying
interesting existential things uh
about choice and all that but i i i
don't know that we have to
read these these things back back inward
in there
all right um let's see here
just skip down a bit um
dale asks have i provided works of
hermann hesse what's my opinion opinion
of him
i read um siddhartha uh
i've read a few other things here and
there um what i've what i've read
has not been sufficiently compelling to
me to
read more hessa i understand that you
think he's really great
author um you know you know it's
different
different tastes for different uh people
i i don't really get into so much
um vern venour do i have any
recommendations for post-human
philosophy readings
well i don't think i think i'm just
human so uh and
i don't think really too many of the
other people that i read are post-human
and so
i don't really have any recommendations
for that
uh somebody asked will you be doing a
series he's in aristotle metaphysics i
already did what he did is on
aristotle's metaphysics
just just on one though i mean see
enough to
sir church in the channel and find
anything that you that you want to find
um guardian dudes says what advice
advice would you give one in their
mid-30s who wants to re-engage
in faith after being more or less lacks
a day-to-day
religious practice uh
i would say reading literature is going
to be a big part you know you know
scriptures find the ones that you want
to read
you know don't force yourself to stuff
that you find
uh my mind numbing warring like you know
these
endless lists of where military forces
came from from the various tribes of
israel in some of the historical works
you know if you're interested in uh
philosophy i feed the wisdom literature
ecclesiastes and job and then uh you
know the soldier actually can consider
wisdom mature as well but public probes
uh book of wisdom wisdom of benson to
rock
all those sorts of things and then you
want to read
other their thinkers who
uh who have something to say so it could
be contemporary
fig figures at the 20th century thinkers
like gabriel marcel
who definitely a person attuned to the
difficult difficulties of believing
in action could be you know you know
readings confessions
could be you know reading cool cool
stuff clementa
vale andreas you know stradadas his
other
fathers you just want to reread some
some some stuff and then you know uh
connect with people who are similarly
interested
worry less less about their um
[Music]
what their bona fides are or
you know you're getting the best version
of it
and start exploring and connect with it
to your life and say
you know all right um
nausea says what are some good primers
to get into german idealism
i don't know i don't read a lot of
second literature and i don't i don't
read
primers so i don't i don't i don't sell
a lot of time on those
like production to such and such and
such
we all we all have limited time and and
i'm not i'm not a good person to ask
about that
so
all right um let's see
here
a bunch of stuff about audio
bark look lord all right familiar with
john scottis here at gina's work i am
indeed indeed familiar with john scottis
era gene's work
um kaido love love what would you
recommend reading my chest off
after all things are possible um
you know he's got a good [ __ ] on doso
yes nietzsche
uh all of this by the way the way you
can available for free mine
athens and jerusalem is considered by a
lot of people to be his best work that's
actually part of the christian falafel
debates he got involved in those in the
you know mid-thirties uh with a set of
articles
reviewed metaphysical morale um
and job's balances is is good there's
also all sorts
you just like you know type in type in
lev
text sex it'll take you to that angel
site
which has his his available for for free
and you kind of
be around in there you know
all right uh current what do you think
do you think of the view
austrian school school of economics is
more of a flaws and a scientific
analysis of political
economy well i think that economics is
really all that scientific to begin
with um it's not scientific in the way
that like the natural sciences are
scientific
um it's certainly a social science and
is there any school in economics or
sociology or psychology that does not
have philosophical
commitments um often
quite bad ones unthought out ones
i don't think so so one may be different
than
anybody else um yeah that's
that's what i would say uh
all right
thomas asks uh who would share some more
accessible philosophers i'm real
interested in battali
nature young that they seem quite
challenging
and complex um
well i don't know um
what you're going to do then because if
you want to
study them there's no there's no round
study studying them oh yeah battalion
is just trick niche is tricky you want
i i guess you guys you could call the
philosopher if you want to
i mean i'm not sure why i fear that
interested in bataille you'd be that
interested in jung but
uh you know different people uh getting
get into things
but when you're asking about like
simpler
or more accessible loss first um
i don't know i mean i think a very
relative term uh
uh i'm often surprised by what people
that that i run into say they easy for
them them to ruin what's hard for them
to read it's not there's a
universe scale or something that we we
can easily
uh go along along with so
um erik's friends and i are reading duty
of g genius
the stein bio alongside the tractatus
anything to be
aware of that i prevent misunderstanding
yeah and the tractatus is a very limited
piece and wittenstein
sententially repudiates its iran
um he was one of people who was sort of
like in the place at the right time
when philosophy had some impoverished
itself
um ray monk is a good
biographer i i don't think that there's
anything that you have to worry about
about
that i'm actually connected with him on
twitter and he seems to be a genuinely
laden person
um vitkenheim is is in many respects
you know you know his work sort of like
a whole series of
interesting missed occasions and
so you know it's kind of cool cool
you're reading the track today don't
expect to get that much of it
you know um even i mean like the
philosophical invasions and
uncertain remarks on the phone the
foundations of maddox
there's interesting stuff there but
there's there's not that much to get out
of it i
would say oh all right
um let's see here
james what are your thoughts on ethical
intuitionism i understand
and intuition are unavoidable and for
one fluffy i'm skeptical of it as a
moral theory we have theories to
do better intuitions so i think you may
have misread
if you're taught debbie ross raw
us doesn't think that everything just
boils down to into intuitions
um and so either either you've write
what ross has to say about this about
this or red glosses
and the losses were more mistakes taken
um
robust you actually ross is you know
think about this yes ross
is a translator aristotle and
commentator in aristotle
wrote his decision on emmanuel kant
comes out with the right and the good
if you read that every only reads
chapter two of it you could read the
rest of it um he doesn't think that we
just like heck have blind intuitions
it's about about he thinks that we can
pick out uh primo fashion should do this
and this
this continues on on down doesn't by the
way with robert hoody who's
another very important person within the
field of ethics
and who definitely wouldn't think that
we just like follow our gut or something
like that
uh there are a lot of people who talk
about indications in philosophy
but but not ethical intuitionists they
are people who usually analytical
philosophers
love to talk about their intuitions and
then you know they
they talk whether they think they think
other people use intuition tuition or
not
and that's a whole separate converse
conversation though
i teach ross in my classes at the primo
duties actually i teach
ross and both particularly in this
ethics i think it's it's a useful
approach
i don't capture is everything everything
that we could capture but but i think
that
it's it's quite good why
is kkk uh how do you think one should
handle mental race in particular clearly
one is subjected to some racism or
verbal pounds by white people well i
don't think there's a
one single response for that
it really depends on the situation
um in some cases it could be good to
like confront it and call it out in
other cases
um you know it's probably not going to
do much of anything
which is is isn't to say it's it's wrong
then to call it out it's just
that if you're dealing with hardcore
racists um
you you confronting them is probably not
going to get them to change their mind
the
the pressure a lot of people confronting
them that that often to ricans consider
um you know the other thing
i suppose to keep in mind you want to
have a proportional
response this is where sometimes things
things are missing
there is some horrible racism
going on at any given given moment
probably just
when this this city of milwaukee let me
let alone our
state of wisconsin further north and
west all the more racist people get
in general um
so you can be guaranteed that there's
some some stuff going on
microaggressions and stuff like that
um sometimes so they are what what we
claim that to be sometimes they're not
and i think
you know proportion coming back to
reality is quite important
um
verbal put downs that's that's that's
that's more you know
click cut i i you know i would say
pushing bang bang is
is important um um it's not gonna
usually much in any given given one
situation and
it might actually bring you you know put
it on you is
as well so oh all right
uh sean have i read any notes by robert
or graves i don't think so
um justin marty david hume was literally
wrong about everything it's impossible
to be literally wrong about everything
so your statement is literally false
it's very hyper hyperbolic
um there's actually a lot of things that
humans quite write a bit about
and i think we should you know when
we're we're considering
philosophy again i just use that word
proportionality we always want to be
proportionate in what we're criticizing
um all right uh andrew do you think
they're with her without humoring
there'd be any philosophers
kind of a kind of a point there's always
human suffering
are you asking whether you think the the
origin of
philosophy is suffering and i mean
philosophers who
have identified other origins of
philosophy going all the way all the way
back to
plato nato and airstone philosophy began
wonder
epictetus has said that philosophy
begins in the conflict
between bulls um statement submits about
that trying to figure out which one's
actually correct
so i suppose that could entail suffering
but you know i i don't think that you
have to say that philosophy
is primarily motivated by
by human suffering so
all right uh nausea what's your advice
for someone
wanting to go into acadeca um
well it's going to be a tough market
you know and if you are
going to go to academia you be because
of the way game is
misplayed you want to go to a grad
school
your final degree that's as high 2 can
and here has nothing to do with merit
what's whatsoever
it just has tested social prestige and
it may be very diff maybe different by
the time you're actually
down the line going for a phd and then
after you have that you
might still not find a job or you might
be bouncing around from one
you know uh contract
to another other so it's it's it's
uh life to live and you probably want to
figure
out a plan b um um there's nothing
wrong with hitting something like that
but if you really want to go into
academia
um there there's ways that you could so
all right uh
iraq lately started with phenomenology
but your commentary and analysis is
really helpful
i'm glad to hear about it um
yeah i've been able to do more of the
half hour kegel lately lately which is
kind of nice nice
um isaac as what should i do
ever ever send my quest for knowledge in
one want to become an astro i've seen
seem to disappoint parents
fights in i've become an atheist
recently again they got heavily in
philosophy i've been weaping her ever
since but they accept that fact they
keep they keep trying to hurt me and
push i definitely logical not coherent
and
i have honest to discuss gosh but they
just seek
over me well there's not much you're
going to be able to do
in that case and so you probably
have to prepare for the long haul of
unfortunately have people that you're
close to
in in really mental disagreement over
and over views with you
um ducks but
you can't you can't you can't uh change
their mind there's no magic wand that
you can win way that will
do that um it's up to you whether the
you know
anguish caused by all this conflict
is is to the point where you want to
want to you know sort of like
like take off relationships with them or
try to try to keep back at it
but um yeah
so i mean
you might you might think about like
well what do you find
that you said in common with them or
what do you use or love
that that could be helpful but that's
that's a tough one
um i don't know that that much that you
can you can do
about that i mean you know you could
also also
if you have this as a possibility
you could bring this up with a third
party and and
they um do you think you could
kind of help out here you know like
maybe other family member
or a friend of the family family that
that
that might be useful
all right fizzy what's up eagles brick
of philosophy last year's science of
logic not the
philosophical of righteousness well well
that's just wrong so there's nothing to
discuss
i mean books so
uh johann says as to the stoics offer
any advice based on being motivated
on a project when results are far far
away with their own advice
um they don't offer advice
on that per se i would say
um but they
do offer um
[Music]
advice about how like like how to mind
yourself about what doing
long long term it's less about
particular like say work projects and
it's more more about like remind
bringing yourself back to yourself and
reminding minding yourself philosophy
is the art of life and you want to live
a happier life so i guess you could you
could connect connect your
long term project with that and you
could you could you could remind off
that you're developing
you know things fall under the virtue of
courage or forward afforded like
perseverance
like like you know sting with things um
that might be helpful for you
all right uh
justin says which socratic
thinker i like the most according to
their ideas is
that's a tough one because we we have so
little of their
their texts right we have fragments of
different people
we don't have like heraclitus's book on
nature
if we had that maybe you know maybe he'd
be my favorite one
um it's tough that that's a tough one i
don't know
what to say i mean i enjoy
reading around inheritance i have to be
very careful about like
blowing the fragments that we have into
more of them better than they are
parmenides is really cool uh to think
through
although i don't buy into him to his
eggs at all
um those i mean i mean like sort of like
plato those those two would be my
favorite plato you know you know in
later dialogues is
talking about like bring those two
together um
but you know we just we just don't have
enough of those those those curse
so i mean maybe if we hadn't had like
pythagoras stuff
it would be interesting but i don't know
all right uh almost how's my knee
same as always you know a lot of people
when they watched my video where i
talked about
tearing ligaments in my knee they didn't
pace enough attention
and realize that i turn my ligaments
back back 2013
you know when i was living in new york
york uh
and that i've been dealing with it since
you know it's you know it's as
as always i've strengthened the muscles
around it as much as possible
you know max that out out basie and and
be careful
you know uh not not uh to screw it up
but but it's not the end of the
world um matter of fact one of our our
most most important player the packers
is acl
a couple days days ago uh bach tr now
he'll get a reply because he's still a
young guy
but you know this is a pretty good thing
to happen
um a lot a lot of people i had students
who actually actually acls was when i
was teenage
stay athletes so
all right uh gabriel says
have do you read many sociology authors
which would be
favorite now if you're talking about
people who just identify strictly as a
sociologist
no no not really most of them doing
quantitative analysis
you know um same with polly i
read too many of them but there's a lot
of overlap between
sociology and philosophy because you
know sociology out of philosophy right
uh august compt uh coins the term
and so you know i've read a lot of the
early so sociologists
and and they're you know doing wing work
that is pretty pretty philosophical
so i i i think they're pretty
interesting
um i don't read of contemporary
sociology unless i i need to some sort
of
project so so all right morgan have you
read
any indigenous authors what are your
thoughts and reconciliation it's between
indigenousness and
indigenous people yeah yeah i've read i
mean i i used to actually
uh by by request when i was teaching at
the prison because there was a
significant
uh native american community there
actually to the point of the point where
they
obtained permission to build the sweat
lodge
that we used to teach classes uh where
we do seminars in our
uh native american spirituality and they
had a significant library
there that they had gathered so i've you
know i've read read people but
it's not like a specialty of mine
anymore than chinese and he's
lost he is what do i think i think of
recifiliation fsnf between indigenous
and non-non-indigenous people
um i think they're great
and i think and i think that radiation
effort effort and you know projects are
great in
general but that that one always to be
realistic
you know um
most people who are aggressors who or
who benefited from something
are gonna they're much more willing to
give like lip service or do token
gestures and they're not not really all
that invested in
in actual reconciliation which is you
know it's a big problem
reconciliation is needed because of
historical trauma which is a real thing
you know
a lot of people wanted to deny it
because they want to have like a blank
slate so they can
feel like everything that they're doing
is perfectly fine
no that's that's often the case um
there's only so much you can do
depending on who the who the parties are
with
those sort of efforts though so
um andrew have you been impressed by
any from dostoyevsky and what is what is
yeah i i find devsky very impressive
um i think that he he's a really
interesting author and i love
how he has these characters who
are expressing philosophy right and
raising it
in very interesting ways is they're
never using it by saying
you know hegel says casas or if this
person's in here here's
always like here's here's some ideas and
here's how i'm trying to make sense of
the world
using that um and then they have our
arguments with each other and they live
out the loss of fees or they fail to and
in certain ways and i i i
find really quite interesting and then
you've got all the other mix of like you
know human sexuality
and what we do in life anything and you
know all of these questions and
dostoyevsky himself
doesn't want to see
um you know you know
tell what his point of point of view is
and that that that bach
is quite quite cracked that does stay
outside in that respect
um all right um
let's go down um
into deonisis the disdain of thought
thought that one arts
with okay i know what that means
move on um
walter white asks how consistent do you
think liam james pragmatism
is uh consistent with what consistent
with itself
um i'm not not sure
what consistency means there are
are you seeing like a sort of sort of a
medium is pragmatism itself pragmatic
you know that that's a little bit to
talk to
to answer uh um
all right isaac says as i would hear
your insight on biblical slavery usually
when i have a discussion on peanut
people it's not true slavery
or was because because of
co-appropriation
i'm curious i don't i don't know what
i'd be connected with cultural
appropriation
it was justified what views do you hold
is it all an omnipotent being immoral or
evil because this are you simply not
able to judge a moral superiority i
would say all those all those are wrong
i i would i would say slavery is existed
in basically every society that
that made it to at a grand level
it was a constant of human
existence and i mean you can even find
like in the huma alicia
right why are human beings created to be
slaves of the god so slavery
or servitude however you want to name it
has been around for a very long time
it would be weird for not to be in
ancient texts
right whether they're hebrew hebrew
greek
latin chinese pick whatever whatever you
want
um and
you know are you saying like god should
have you know waved his hand and made
him
not a slave there's also all sorts of
discs about like freeing captives and
slaves saves
the bible i think it's a major theme you
know the
exodus you know about that so
i i i don't is a real really central
issue i mean you can you can raise is
like paul
and tithy should should paul have like
you know going on against institution of
slavery as such
um that that that's a question then like
the whole of you know
ancient ancient culture um
and what i think you can find and and
just in biblical literature also like
say in seneca has a lot of
discussions about slavery or epictetus
who himself was was a slave
um there's different ways to understand
slavery
um there's a huge verb how people are
treated
uh is there are there a lot of people
rejecting the institution of slavery
per se there were some very few uh
aristotle
talks of that in paul paul's book what
he says some people people say that
slavery is always unnatural therefore
against justice
but he does he doesn't know who they are
and you get the idea that they're like
like an exposition in ancient culture
so lucy is a lot of emphasis on
understanding the shared humidity with
the slightly not not
treating them in in a purely demonic
manner
um so i guess that would be
my my view on it it's kind of an on view
but i don't know what to tell you
all right um quinn says
hope you're doing well do you have any
opinions or
thought on the enlightenment
philosophers particularly fairly french
reading rousseau oh and was ring what
who think is value valuable from period
so rousseau's kind of a weird weirdo in
that right
he is in the enlightenment but also kind
of critical
of the enlightenment but i can make
comparison people like dahlem bear and
uh adida rita rowe and some of the
other thinkers that fit into that time
many of them are by by the way
influenced by lock in the french
thinkers
um so i think they're
interesting and they're well worth
beating i mean if you understand
and how we got here today let's say
you're a big mac i can tell your fin
right
i was just talking with a client about
yesterday and the enlightenment project
i don't understand what enlightenment
project it is you probably got to read
some of these enlightenment things
anchors
russo though like hey he's kind of a
weird
guy in this respect he he's
for the enlightenment there's certain
themes that that he corresponds with
um like being critical of political
power religious power
um projecting out um some better better
a
some more rational way of living
together but he's also also optimistic
and suspicious
of how this is actually actually going
to work by comparison to send to some of
these
these other much more optimistic
thinkers
who are like just get rid of the
arbitrary very political part of the
priest craft and
you know so super stint uh you know
human
rationality will be be free we'll have
this this
uh society we'll we'll take everybody
he's gonna be hungry you know criminal
justice this will actually be
coherent rousseau's kind of
suspicious of that isn't it so yeah
and and so was also a guy who had a lot
of psychological problems
i mean he was prick that he managed to
get um
david hume not to like him after a while
and that that that took
um and so yeah he's
they're all well worth reading i'd say
um
all right uh andrew asks any chance of a
video series
dostoyevsky's the idiot and the demons
are possessed um different translations
of
that work yeah i've been wanting to get
to the the
the demons the pizza possess quite a
while
um maybe sometime this year the idiot
probably probably not uh not on somebody
commissions me
i just don't don't see the book as
having the
philosophical death i i actually my
favorite dostoevsky work is is
is the best i like it better than i like
the bruce karamazov
or you know notes from underground or
crime punishment
um i haven't read the idiot for a while
so maybe i'm wrong about this but i i
just did see as much
philosophical meat to to engage in there
but i i could be wrong you know no
all right um derrick harris just watched
the documentary about hanukkah
vida octiva what's your thoughts on
banality
preservation is a evil in the prevailing
american culture of
pragmatism i don't know that there is a
prevailing american culture of
pragmatism i think pragmatism is a
philosophy would say they say that
muslims are pretty
pragmatic so i'm not sure what that
means
um i mean if we want to talk about like
oh consumerism or something like that
that that could america my thoughts on
benality
as a pathway to evil i mean
when a rent talks about the reality of
evil though this is not a
theory about the trival evil
it's not she thinks that that's the
essence of evils and kant had it wrong
with radical evil
she's saying in some cases this is an
aspect of evil that's often been
left out and you know it wasn't just
about
following orders or scissors like that
you know when she's talking about
eichmann
eichmann was
a cliche written person she talked about
him as unable to
to address other people or the world or
what he did
except by using clean clays
um and you know
a lot of americans things like that but
there's a lot a lot like that everywhere
at any time i don't see that as that as
you the american
[Music]
so all right
uh louis what's your take on the fate
laws of
power i mean i mean there's all sorts of
works that's out there
like that um all sorts of stuff healthy
or you know how machiavelli leads the
way
kind of things i mean i mean if people
are interested in that sort of thing
you know they could spending their time
reading philosophy uh
rather than you know reading stuff like
that but
um what are you gonna do right that's
that's
what it typically is and it's part of a
genre genre that's on for a very long
time
there's going to be new iterations of it
um maxwell has has a question here how
do i
introduce the metaphysic physics of
humanity to my seller progressive
leftist friends and family do you think
the average secular
person thinks about metaphysical physics
and i don't even know what the physics
of christianity is
you know you know so i i mean i mean
there's a great book out there by
and simpson think you know christian
matter of fact so that i i ran into when
i was doing my doing my work on
uh chris christian philosophies there is
no no single metaphysics
i i don't know where the term is coming
from it's probably from
some secondary work or some particular
authentic author means their
metaphysics that it has something to do
with christianity
um so i don't know how you would
introduce it to your your
secular progressive leftist friends i
would say that
if you want to get your secular left
left arrest of friends
interested in christianity um
maybe what you do is you live live a
christian life
that's by following following the stern
on the mount
and you show them them through
you know the kind of life life and the
things things that you do
and the things that you say and don't
don't say what what
what christianity has to offer to people
well i mean thing with like stoic
if you want to get people incident
stoicism uh it's
less effective to be like this is going
to change your your life manner this is
this is the true
understanding of things and it's more
like well you have a certain way and
polite
why are you so so happy well i've got
this thing going on
you know it's changing things that that
might be a way to go about it i would
uh andrew what do you think of
bukowkowski not a fan
i mean i i sort of didn't did my
editorial reading of bukowski
in the 90s when people were introducing
him to me and i was like well this is a
great
great piece for the kind of like scumbag
bar flies that i know and hang around
with
but i i i don't see much
hear this very eerie entering sort of
like you know
in some respects norman mailer redux
[Music]
and i just i never never found
much uh all that interesting in him i
guess a lot a lot of people do
all right uh would you consider doing a
book review review of george orwell's
nells 1984
i wouldn't do a review i would consider
doing
core cut videos or you know something
else
the book reviews that i do with adler's
honestness reviews about like you know
more or less contemporary philosophy
self-help
leadership all that sort of stuff like
how to how to improve your life kind of
books
i don't know the church of wallace 1984.
it's it's into that all well um
but yeah i'd consider consider uh
doing doing uh something i think i mean
we'll fit it into the world of
speculative relative addiction
seriously time as well uh
maybe we'll just shoot on george orwell
not this year because we already have
all the things
laid out um so
all right uh anger here
i want the list of all philosophical
questions who's here to find a
philosophical position
not even sure whether what that means so
i'm going to skip over that one um
let's see here
just skipped a dipped a bit rt whitby b
what are you the philosopher of my
memories
uh you know interesting per person to
read i'm not an expert i've heard on
oddities
um i've read i've read some of his
i don't draw on him very much so you
know i'm usually only going back to him
when there's
something that i think that i like to
check out but a lot of people like him
uh laulani uh i read some of
leviathanathon what else
read by thomas hobbes read leviathan
again again and again again
and just book one and boom book two
because book three and book four
are hot wild crazy totally
relevant political theology
that even hob scholars false part don't
don't bother with with
read reading but levi is his
his best work you may not know this but
hobbs actually
one of the sets that's selections to
descartes um
missions and that's worth checking out
too
uh hobbs and descartes cart didn't get
along too
this also has uh um another work that i
really do
recommend i mean you can also read all
these other works that can feed into the
leviathan like the decay
and all that but he wrote another book
called behemoth
or the long parliament and
leviathan and hemeth are these these
biblical creatures right right
and so these are companion piece book
books hemeth
tells you the story from hobbes's point
of point of view somebody who lived
through it
of how everything broke down
in britain to a civil war
and how the different people were
murdering and when you read that as
as a companion used to levion there's
parts of leviathan
we're like oh that's what he's talking
about
that's that's that's why he's so worried
about
divines meaning theologians preaching
about this sort of thing he wants this
estate to
censure that or shut them down because
this led to this and this is
um this is why he thinks this the state
has this absolutely
power so behemoth is a really good good
book to check
out um
tyson which dutch style does play to
bring heraclitus
and permanentes together here i always
get these mixed up it's all the later
ones i think it's a sofas
uh or it's not the statesman right i
think it's the solst in which he he
talks about that um
bizarre can you please please say a few
words the legacy of leo
strauss you generally really think about
his work ideas is
astral traumas his kind of vacant rate
eight there and in my view
um he certainly was chasmatic he has
this like
esoteric territory things that i decided
to jump into
socials i've i've known quite a few a
few of them
i i don't find them particularly
interesting and then their hero worship
of strauss
you know in the past has been a little
bit off-putting
um that said sometimes he has his
interesting things to contribute i
cited him before liking my work on on
hobbs
um so i just you know you know i
see him as somebody who i want to spend
a lot of time in in my reigning years
but
yeah um john sherlock your opinion on
old spengler and the decline of the west
and philosophy in general
so philosophy of history in general you
got you got to be careful with it
a lot of it's pretty schlocky stuff and
i say that spangler
it's been a long time a long time since
i'm when i did i did i'm not impressed
um people who like think that he's the
greatest
almost invariably try to be you know
poorly read and kind of kind of cookie
um they're really more attracted to some
of the the
things in a message or which or what
they got somebody else
um i mean as mean is he worried
sure i mean just just as much a goose
comp is worth reading or
herbert spencer is um
philosophy of history is tough to do
because history is so damn
complex anytime you're like i figured
out direction history is going
pretty soon history will come around and
and show you wrong
so yeah i i don't i don't know um i
don't i don't have a lot of views on the
loss of history history
um penn tree what do you think of the
flaws lost philip
uh so i i don't know enough about him it
could be it could be intro
uh he asked do you have any thoughts on
delusions and terp interpretation eagle
that runs through his bookshed
philosophy it's been a long time time
since i read i actually
present on that in grad school and i
don't think i've read events
um so i don't really remember too
well what his his uh views on hale were
in that book
um it's nilo have you read
humor as a response to nihilism by john
mar marmiz what are your thoughts
on i i've never heard of him um or the
but it sounds quite interesting and the
reason why i think it
sounds interesting is that um
i um
you know i i i very much an attractive
practitioner and i think that
humor is a good thing and
um often all we can
can do is laugh now there's ways of
laughing nothing that i think are
not particularly helpful we talking can
come about pushing down
i don't know like finding somebody just
to make fun of who's weak weaker in us
or
in worse opposition than than us i don't
think that's cool
but i think sometimes we do have to
laugh at how screwed up things i don't
even think
necessarily has to be nihilism um
but and you know some sometimes some
kinds of neoliberalist
approaches or people if we make fun of
them or we laugh
at them we don't like make them no
longer
needless but we de-fang them
you know so that sounds like an
interesting
perhaps promising um
point of view all right here's a picture
question
from us no it's my opinion can you not
demonstrate do i think
democratic nations are sometimes debated
to compare competitive nations
sometimes they are and sometimes they're
not i mean it really
it really depends on what we're talking
about if your goal is to
to to know what people think
democracy really works better than
accuracy if your goal is to have a
functioning economy
um there aren't a hell of a lot of you
know autocratic
um places that are doing all that great
you know singapore off it's gets
mentioned as like you know a good
example but
uh i forget exactly how they there's a
term that they you
use for where it's it's democratic in
some respects but
you got democrat who's who's on top
um most operatic regimes historically
uh ended up missing many many
opportunities
but that could also be less about
democracy as such and more about rule of
law
you know or more about um capitalists
and other
types of economic uh things you know
autocratic regimes don't do capitalism
very well
usually without being way crony cap
capital and then
what we've we've got i mean here here in
the united states
um
we don't have have a funk democracy in
every respect in many respects we don't
have
many parts of the citizenry who are not
adequately represented
and who are targeted by you know
instruments of state power whether at
the federal or at the
local levels um
we're kind of we're not we're less
certainly less democratic than we were
when i was a kid
um we we've sort of sort of said
backwards in many areas
but you know i i don't there's a lot of
to point to is like
billy getting things right that way
um all right
uh matthew most of my reading has been
broadly chronological therefore i'll be
running into cuts soon oh good
can you help with where to start i'm
pretty patient with my my reading
happiness by spending on text well i
mean kant
wrote wrote the prominent that's the
read this
first so i would i would that before
jumping to the critiques uh likewise the
groundwork work for the medics of moral
that's that's a good starter text
uh i would actually be reading it around
before you jump into i'm gonna read the
read the critiques read some of his
various essays like you know a perpetual
piece or
you know you know some of these effects
that you can you can get your hands on
where he's writing
a more popular one um
and then you know you can you can launch
and you can do the critiques in their
order first critique
critique of pure reason second critique
critique of practical reason
critique critique of judgment that's a
weird one book
um and you don't have to feel like you
have to totally
understand all those those parts parts
this critique is way easier than the
first first or the third
i found um and then you know
there's things like religion within the
limits of recent reasons which is
definitely worthing
which turns out to be more and more
about f's than anything
else you know i mean that's kind of the
things
that they're often misnamed um
but that's that's what i would do um
team ago have you read critic of
dialectical reasons search method
material and then revolution or any of
search marks work yes but it's been a
long time ago and i haven't read
since so much to say about it
um all right
vadassi says greetings from russia i
wanted to ask your opinion about chinese
peacefully
asian philosophy in general have you
read any of any was it rarely studied in
the west yeah i started reading
chinese philosophies back as an
undergraduate
and i've taught classes on it from time
to time are incorporating
i will still say the chinese
philosophical
tradition or we even expand spain east
asia
where china is sort of sort of at the
center we also include include korea
japan
vietnam now there's uh it's
vast you know there's so much air
it goes way way back back there's some
interesting movement
study handicapped in that i i don't read
uh uh chinese other than like about
200 characters from from one studying in
a while back
alone classic chinese so i i'm dependent
on
other people's translations in a way i'm
not say with like the stoics where i can
go to the greek or the latin um
so i'm always a little bit worried about
whether i'm getting the stuff right
and i don't consider myself an expert on
it but i do think it's
well with studying and i try to
incorporate into like my intro
introduction philosophy classes as we
can
like this around with philosophy of
human nature we're going to we're going
to be eating
some confucian uh analects and
to the menses right so i i think it's
well worth reading
why is it rarely studied west most
people are rarely studied in the west
you know even west philosophers are many
of them are rarely studied in the west
uh i was surprised to find out that most
of my
colleagues was when they each descart
and then they teach them patients they
only only teach meditations one and two
two
they don't teach the whole in book you
know and you're like well why why
why would you do that there well let's
don't find the rest of it interesting or
we had to you know we have to do it in a
short amount of more i just don't know
all the rest
so it's it's it's you know it's part of
a bigger problem i think you could say
and we can also extend this to india
philosophy
or to islamic philosophy or to other
other you know areas as well why aren't
we teaching them
well well we're usually just teaching a
very very narrow
amount of stuff and anytime that we
bring something new
in an academic way we got something out
so we're always doing what we call trees
in deciding who who who's and who's out
and that makes it tough um
but that's a good question um
all right uh lars is asking if you've
come across any of
william reich's word the one who wrote
about about word energy
yeah i mean red reich like a long time
ago
and that's some weird wacky wild stuff
too isn't
um so for those who don't know william
reich was a psychoanalyst
for his own direction uh
very different developed his own sort of
organization and a pro road
and um there are strikians out there
there today but there are a very
small small group
all right um
yakuz how can i confirm there's a ball
without utilizing a logical fallacy
i don't i don't know man that's that's
really not the thing i've really
worried too much about maybe somebody
else can help help you out
with that one so all right uh
i just skipped a bit let's see let me
scroll
back there we go
um
people are saying like the idea the idea
of 94
um
a lot of people talk back and forth
about audio issues
over which i don't need control we've
already addressed that
minimus have you read lacan of an event
yeah read a little look on you know um
i was in the uh faculty seminar led by
aleister mcintyre
on practical rationality back in 2005
where we considered uh aristotle and
ptolemism
and uh rational choice theory and then
fighting
and and i you know i studied anybody who
was also a practice psychoanalyst
and did work on la casa in grade school
um i i read quite a bit huh
i also published a few things things on
the con there
it's not as much as i would like but
yeah i i i know some of the
comm so all right uh
let's see here
don asks uh any tips on processing
emotions is in a healthy healthy way i
often follow the gap of suppressing
or avoiding negative emotions
yeah so you start where you are
and this holds not just for stoicism but
if you were going to take a rick and a
resilient approach
or you know look at it through buddhist
life lens whatever is going to be right
also you know christian discourses on
the emotions you start out where you are
and that's probably
screwed up and that's probably with with
them with emotional whack
and then doing things that they're you
know their best bond senses
and you know you know afterwards you
feel upset about it
you've you've got to start where and so
it's repressing your emotions
or trying to avoid uh circumstances
where they might get well probably
probably not get helpful
and that you decide what you want to
focus on
do you want to want to focus on
understanding
why your emotional emotions arrive in
the situations okay there's
there's practice you can do with that
and insight that you can apply
to that do you want to like figure out
where your emotional responses are off
base
what a better set of response it might
be okay there's practices for that as
well you know
and you can start putting these things
together you do it with babies you be
stuck and you do it with
iteration and you keep track of over
time
and you you out to other people who
have gotten not you know further along
the way and as resources for that and
you keep reading as well
um you know fortunately for certain
emotions there's there's some
helpful links out there like seneca's
got a great book on anger anger right
uh do i have to buy into everything that
he's saying
no no not necessarily but you can use
usually you could use some of the
insights so you know that that's
what i say you can you can do by way of
advice
all right dc frank do you think there's
a problem problem with hoob and snobbery
and
active philosophy do you think they
think there's a lot of fight and wisdom
lost as a result there's a problem with
hubris and snobbery
in in every single fact every single
name of human
life right so why should academic
academics would be any
different because it's philosophy right
um
no i mean philosophers are human beings
subject to the same same sort of
psychological dynamics as everybody else
um i'm sure there's plenty of of hurus
and there's plenty there's plenty
um and insights gets get lost
uh and uh so you know what what's what's
the uh uh
the recurs uh you know try to find find
this is where that's not the case case
it's it's it's not like the case
everybody or everywhere or
all the time um um
[Music]
find intuitions find people who
who are more or genuine in that respect
and sit down um
all right fatal remaining say dr adler i
read your paper on the com
and the ethics of psychoanalysis i'm
still wondering how one discusses
ethical psychoanalytic practice from
malpractice
unethical actions in therapy you
probably saw one oh how one discerns
ethical
psychoanalytic practice well i mean part
of this is institutional right
you're supposed to not just be winging
it going off on your own
and doing things without any supervision
and you're supposed to
engage with other psychotherapists now
i'm not a therapist by the way you know
i'm physical counselors but um
the actual psychological psychoanalytic
institutions out
they they try to ensure that they're
that there's a lot of kind of
peer review and uh can you can you
rule out all you know male practice all
say exploitation of patients or stuff
stuff like that probably not
right right um you have to ask ask
yourself a logical
question though what's the goal here
here is it to
you know fully cure the patient it's not
laconia and psychoquinone
although that is other kinds of echo
analysis
um is it to attain is it to allow them
to
attain a greater agency um
and and a capacity to make sense answer
their
life not just to enable them for bad
behaviors but
to you know allow them a certain
riffiness on on where they they are and
where they've been and how they're
moving forward
those are the sort of things that you
that you yes there is no hard and fast
rule for that there's no line we could
say oh there are some lots of line
sleeping with it for the patient
unethical just as much as much
by this but as a bit of a rant there's
no times when a
professor should sleep with a student
you know that's just so stupid um
there's a power differential there
and you can say oh what about this
particular
uh uh case you know what weight mean to
a student
same thing with with a pace you don't
sleep with the patients right
why not well because you're exploiting a
a situation in which there's a power
imbalance so there's probably a lot of
transference going on right so there are
some rules like that
but then you get to like well what about
this what about this
you know i i say that um in a lot of
cases this is asking
asking those sorts of questions is
assigning you probably should say no
i'll look this over here um
yeah all right let's see what else we we
got here
since we're getting to the end um
[Music]
okay so aaron lopez lopez i'm having a
hard time understanding the concept of
telly tell y'all wondering if you can
explain concept or point me to a
resource tell the audiologist ends in
any means
things are directed towards ends towards
words goals purposes
there's nothing mysterious about this um
even asking
your question your question has a
telltale right you're asking it in order
to get it in an answer
it's it's it's it's not anything there's
probably somebody who's like
teleteleology the principal paul no
challenges just referring us to
things being dread to particular ends or
goals or purposes
that's all it really means um
all right alex asked do i have i read
joseph peeper or max picard i've read
some paper
ways back never heard of picard so
uh uh what about the contemporary debate
hegel reverses duluz i would say anybody
anybody wasting their time on that
is probably you know do it do exactly
wasting their thing their time why we
why would we have a debate
versus to lose like as if these are like
like you know the two thinkers
that capture everything um
all right low down
uh x asks a question here
currently reading being in time do you
think it's wise to keep reading at
moments when i don't get what he is
saying yes
and the first time that you read text
you just read it all the way
even if you don't understand it all the
way you're gonna go back and re-read it
right so keep going through some
sometimes the answer this is something
that you're looking for
or laying on down the line
turns out to be in a later chapter and
you're like oh that's what
that was talking about early on in the
beginning of being in time heimhar uses
this terminology of ontake and
oncological and doesn't buzz and
clarify what the hell he's talking about
you know that cannot control people for
for a loop right um
so that that that's a that's a problem
um
but yeah i would i would keep fly away
at it and just expect that you're gonna
have to reread and and then and that's
okay
that's that's totally normal that's the
way
that's the way it works it's in
philosophy but the way i'm gonna create
some
videos for my academic students also for
other other people think about these
these these sort of things
i'm going to read you the how to read a
philosophical text video that i did
pretty eight nine years ago back with
you know my
my b i don't think i had had a beard
back but if i did it it was the same
color as my hair
um so
all right uh let's see here
here's a question from why
understanding stingstose is regular
regularly practicing and efficient even
after
acknowledging agency is hard or slippery
is it due to
discipline or something else so stoicism
just other philosophies of life is
is a collect system and there's a those
ideas also also networked ideas and you
have to internalize
and make them part of who you are in
order for those ideas to really
um be fully
real to the to you to you exactly what's
going on
that is a lot of work right that's a
continual practice
you can't hack stoicisms any more than
life hack
any anything else it's worth it you're
gonna do a serious
superficial stuff um you can't make
lasting changes without without doing a
continual iterative
work so again it's normal that
you're going to feel like the lines are
[Music]
kind of slipping out of hand or not
entirely there
right that's that's okay okay so that's
normal
all right um
let's see see here alex says you like
real quick luckily i admired my car
great deal i think i think pedro isn't
directly related hated somehow to burr
uh
okay a lot a lot of people here real
quick uh
marcel actually wrote wrote music for
for for real uh uh poetry um we you know
we have
so many so many hours so many day a week
so many
weeks in the year here who we're going
to go to attention
to uh jonathan mann bell do you think
there's a good case for epistemocracy
for example as indicated by jason
brennan over democracy
well we don't need democracy like i said
before and
and i don't remember brennan's proposals
that well it's a couple years since i
looked i looked
but i don't remember thinking that that
well that's definitely going to work
better i mean john stewart really
advocated hated something
like that where smart people would get
more votes than than
dumber people um but how do you
how do you test that right it's going to
be totally controversial
um so yeah that's that's
it's kind of a non-starter i mean i mean
go ahead go ahead propose epistocracy
and then then see
watch both both the right and the left
turn on you
in in howl mobs i would say
all right uh here we go
let's see here
see have you heard heard of john vecchi
yes i've actually with john
and rebecca so but what um
he's an interesting guy uh published in
stoicism today
if things are in stoicism to them today
since i'm the editor you got that i've
i've
seen right and put it in there um
janet roth what's your opinion on
vladimir nabokov and do his works
do i really like him just like him i've
only i've only lita
and i read that um in a
literature class back in college college
and and i was okay i
didn't i didn't find it great i didn't
find it terrible
uh i don't really i haven't read it or
read any other cough so
i'll tell you kind of kind of a funny
thing to be a good ender so when my
my wife and i and i got there um
a long time ago it's all about it's more
than 10 years now
uh we've been we've been married for
nine years now
um she would ask me of all these
contemporary authors eventually i told
her
listen is it written after 1950 and she
said yeah and i said i
probably probably have that you know
because i spend most of most of my time
bringing
people from past if i if i have read
some 19
19 onward it's probably going to be a
sci-fi fire fantasy author or something
like that you know it's probably not
going to be something cutting edge
content temperature or anything like
that i don't move in those circles i i
don't
really care what the literati think we
ought to read
and so i'm not well read in that respect
you know
and i don't i don't uh i don't i don't i
don't tend to be
um that's a good thing to end and uh
sorry that there's
there's bound issues there's nothing i
can about that
you know everything everything looks
fine on my end
um we'll uh see we'll see what happens
next time
and uh thanks for questions
you